I am extremely pleased to introduce
the fourth and final lecture of the
semester. Uh, uh,
uh,
the director,
he is well known or worked in medical
psychology and especially to research
depression,
the major and complete
with a special focus on,
uh, uh, can do
[inaudible]
and it has author what in my mind is
the very best textbook in her area.
And um,
and she's a,
she's a popular writer or an acceptable
books reading the message and ideas and
go.
The other thing I'll mention before we
welcome her if that he's going to teach
next year record [inaudible] they call it.
We've had it for reputation.
If you are and what you hear today,
you want to learn more about it. Um,
that's the question. It please
welcome Dr. Norman. Huh?
Thank you Paul. Can
everybody hear me okay? Okay.
So what I want to do today is to give
you a very brief overview of how modern
clinical psychology looks
at mental disorders.
Some of the ways we think about
what constitutes a mental disorder,
some of the characteristics that
kind of cut across mental disorders.
And then I'm going to use the case of
mood disorders that is depression and what
is now called bipolar disorder or what
you may know more popularly as manic
depression,
as sort of examples of how we think
about a particular set of disorders.
And some of the ways we go about
researching the theories, uh,
different theories for the disorders
and some of the prominent treatments for
disorders these days. Okay. So I'm
going to do both, um, a fair amount of,
of uh, lecturing. And then I've got lots
of video clips, uh, to show you as well.
So I'm going to be roaming
around and changing venues
here apparent fairly often.
So the first and most fundamental
question in clinical psychology is what is
abnormality? Where do we draw
the line between normal, healthy,
typical behavior and what we
might want to call abnormal,
a typical deviant,
unhealthy,
maladaptive mental problems.
We tend to have an intuitive sense
of what we mean by abnormality.
And we'd like to believe a lot of
people who come into my course. I will,
of course, you know, you guys have figured
it out. You know where to draw the line,
you have criteria, you
have blood tests, right?
That tells me whether I have depression
or schizophrenia or one of the things
I've read about, well the reality
is that that we don't, um,
first of all there is no biological test
for any of the known mental disorders
right now.
Um,
and instead what we have are a set of
behavioral criteria for how to diagnose
different mental disorders.
And what I mean by behavioral criteria
is a set of symptoms that the person
reports to you about how they feel,
how they think,
and a set of observations about their
behavior and how typical or atypical it
is.
And you take the sort of set of symptoms,
the person shows her reports and you match
them up against the existing criteria
for different mental disorders.
And then it comes down to a fairly
subjective judgment call about whether the
person meets the criteria or not.
Unfortunately,
these judgment calls because
they are so subjective,
can be influenced by a lot of factors.
And we won't have a chance to go
into these, uh, too much today.
But just to highlight a few of
them. Um, the first is social norms.
Whether you get labeled as having a
mental disorder or a problem depends very
heavily on what your, um,
social or cultural norms are.
So,
uh,
a woman wearing a veil in a Muslim
community or culture would be seen as
typical,
even prescribed behavior,
whereas a woman wearing a veil in a
non Muslim culture and especially until
fairly recently was,
was often looked upon as very
atypical or abnormal behavior.
The second kind of thing that gets a,
that influences whether
something is called normal,
abnormal are certain characteristics
of the target person in particular I've
highlighted here gender,
um,
whether you're a man or you're a woman
really influences how unusual a certain
behavior is. So crying
is a good example. Uh,
a man crying in our culture
is seen as fairly unusual,
whereas a woman crying as seeing as
much less unusual. On the other hand,
a woman beating up someone is taken as
quite unusual behavior where it's less
unusual for a man. So we have gender
stereotypes, gender roles, um,
for what is acceptable behavior and our
judgements as to whether something is
normal or abnormal, um, get
influenced by those gender roles.
And the third thing that can influence
whether something is labeled abnormal or
not is the context.
And here I'm giving you
the example of paranoia.
If you're paranoid and hyper vigilant
looking for threat in downtown Baghdad,
that's considered very adaptive behavior
these days because it could prevent you
from getting hurt or killed.
Whereas if you're in a
quiet little farm town,
I'm in central Connecticut being extremely
paranoid and, and believing there's,
um, someone who's going to
shoot you around the corner,
uh, is not considered, um,
as, as normal or as acceptable
or adaptive behavior.
So the context in which you exhibit
a particular behavior also can,
can heavily influence whether it gets
labeled by others as normal or abnormal.
In the field of clinical psychology,
um,
we have a number of different ways,
kind of heuristics that we use to,
uh,
label things as,
as abnormal or unhealthy or troubling.
And,
um,
three of these characteristics are
that what we often call the three D's
distress,
dysfunction and deviance.
So behaviors that caused the individual,
um,
or others significant
distress are often getting,
often get labeled as
abnormal or unhealthy.
Depression is a prime example as
we'll see when we talk about the
characteristics of it.
It's a miserable state of being
your urine happy. You're sad,
you may even feel so badly you want
to kill yourself. And that very,
very high level of distress,
um,
is part of the reason why it's
labeled as a mental disorder.
Other mental disorders don't call the
cause of the individual and distress,
but they may cause other
people distress. So, um,
one example of this is something called
antisocial personality disorder where
the individual has no regard for
the rights of other people. Um,
has,
uh,
no hesitation to steal or,
or steal from or hurt other people.
Um,
has no empathy or sympathy for other
people's feelings and so can inflict a lot
of harm on other people and has absolutely
no distress over this whatsoever.
But his behavior causes
other people distress.
And that's one of the reasons why
that's labeled an abnormal behavior or a
mental health problem.
The second general criterion
is dysfunction. If, um,
a set of behaviors prevents the
person from functioning in daily life,
then uh,
it might be labeled as,
as abnormal or might end up being
labeled as a mental health problem.
Again,
depression is a good example.
People who are depressed often
become completely nonfunctional. Um,
they can't get up and go to class.
They can't go to work,
they can't interact with their friends.
They withdraw and become
totally isolated socially. Uh,
so they might lose their job,
they might flunk out of school
and there's complete, um,
a decline in functioning is one of the
major reasons that we consider depression,
one of the most debilitating disorders.
And then finally, deviants. Um,
the behaviors or feelings
are highly unusual.
This is probably the most controversial
of the three because it weighs a, uh,
it is so heavily influenced
by the social norms.
What's deviant in one culture is
not deviant, um, in another culture.
But if a set of behaviors are
completely unacceptable to a culture,
highly unusual, they're more likely
to end up getting labeled as abnormal.
Okay. So how do we pull this
all together? Well, these days,
um,
the manual for making diagnoses in
clinical psychology and psychiatry in the
United States is called the diagnostic
and statistical manual or the DSM.
Um, and it's in its fourth revision.
It's been around since the,
I believe that fifties.
And the early additions in the fifties
and sixties were highly subjective and
based on 40 and theory.
But since 1980,
there's been a real effort to make the
criteria much more objective to make the
set of behaviors or observations that
are required to diagnose someone being
things that,
that are observable,
that you can see in other people that
they can report on reliably and that, um,
one clinician, uh, and another
clinician will agree upon.
So the DSM gives lists of symptoms with
the required symptoms for a diagnosis,
the number of symptoms they have to be
present and the notions of deviation,
dysfunction and distress are
built into these criteria.
And we're going to give you a couple of
examples of these criteria when we talk
about this specific
types of mood disorder.
So there's a,
I'm going to use mood disorders as a
kind of a case example here of how we go
about diagnosing and
understanding psychopathology. Um,
but I also just want to impart some
information because mood disorders are one
of the most common
problems that people face.
As many as a one in four women will have
an episode of a serious depression at
some time in her life and about 13%
of men will have an episode of serious
depression in their lives. So
these are extremely common. Um,
kinds of problems that people experience,
uh, particularly at your age. Um,
the college years are one
of the peak times of onset,
first onset of,
of depression in particular,
and also for bipolar disorder
or manic depression. Um,
the late adolescent,
early twenties are the peak onset
time for these disorders as well.
So the mood disorders divided into
what's called unipolar depression or
disorders,
which is depression only.
And then bipolar disorders where the
person's cycles between depression and
mania.
And here are the DSM criteria
for major depression. Um,
one of the most severe forms
of depression. And as I said,
the DSM sets up these
relatively observable criteria
and how many have to have
and what absolutely has to be present
in order to get the diagnosis.
So the first criteria in the DSM,
uh,
for major depression is that the
individual has to either show sadness or a
diminished interest or pleasure
in their usual activities,
which is referred to as Anhedonia.
So you have to have one or the other
of these two sort of past the first
criterion. So you might say
that you feel sad and blue and,
um, just, uh, or, or actually say you
feel depressed. Some people feel those,
those feelings very strongly. Other
people don't really feel so sad or blue,
but what they'll say is that
nothing interest them anymore.
It's like the emotion has been sucked
out of their life all together. Um,
they don't have any fun doing the
activities they used to do before.
They don't want to hang with
their friends. Um, they just,
they don't care about eating.
Uh, just nothing feels right,
feels good anymore,
and then the individual
has to have four of the,
at least four of the following symptoms
in addition to sadness or hand Hedonia
first they can show significant
weight or appetite change.
Um,
so you may completely lose your interest
in eating and lose a lot of weight or
some people go on eating binges.
I had a very good friend who was depressed
for about a year and she gained 50
pounds because she would just eat. Um,
she would binge eat, especially at night.
There are sleep
disturbances, um, insomnia,
which is having trouble
sleeping or hypersomnia, which
is sleeping all the time.
There's a particular form of insomnia
that's especially likely and depression
where you can go to sleep at night when
you wake up at about three or four in
the morning every night and you
can't go back to sleep at all.
You're just up for the rest of the night.
But other people want
to sleep all day long.
And in the clip I'm going to
show you in just a minute,
the woman talks about sleeping
20, 22 hours a day. Getting up,
eating a little bit, and then going back
to bed because she was exhausted still.
Um, the third criterion is
psychomotor retardation or agitation.
The retardation is much more common.
And what this means is that sort of
everything about the person's movement has
slowed down.
They'll walk more slowly,
their reaction times will be slowed down.
Um,
and because they're so
much more slow moving,
a depressed people are often
more prone to accidents.
They just can't react as quickly as they
need to when they're driving or when
they're crossing the road and a car is
coming at them suddenly. Um, so that,
so they get into more accidents.
Um,
and their speech may be slowed down.
They may talk very,
very slowly.
And it's as though it just takes a
tremendous amount of energy to get even a
common sentence out, uh, much more,
uh, much smaller number of people get
agitated instead of slow down. Um,
they may be hyper and, and just feel
like they can't sit still and such.
But the agitation is a much
more rare than the retardation.
Um,
people feel really tired,
fatigued and like they
have absolutely no energy.
They can't get up and can't
get moving. Um, as I said,
they may want to just
sleep all of the time.
A number five is feelings of
worthlessness or excessive guilt.
They may feel as though everything
is their fault. Um, and the guilt,
feelings or sense of worthlessness
can even get psychotic.
They can lose touch with reality.
When a person loses touch with reality,
when they're depressed,
it typically has really depressing themes.
They may believe that they are,
um,
Satan and that they have to commit suicide
because they're in flipping evil on
the world.
Um,
they may believe is a though random
events or their fault, you know,
that that a flood that just happens
somehow they caused. Um, so the,
the feelings of worthlessness and guilt
can get out of completely out of touch
with reality psychotic more commonly.
They are just unrealistic.
Um,
they're negative self esteem,
just being down on yourself,
um,
feeling stupid and
worthless and ugly and bad.
Okay.
Number six, a diminished ability to
concentrate or in decisiveness. Um,
when you are depressed,
it's really hard to pay attention.
You'll read a passage over and over again
and it just can't process it at all.
Um, you can't concentrate on a lecture,
so going to class is just useless.
You have to make a decision about what
a paper topic is and it just seems like
the most monumental thing on earth.
Um, you just can't decide anything.
You can't think anything. Your thoughts
are completely clouded and overwhelmed.
Yeah.
And then suicidal ideation or behavior,
it means you think about
committing suicide.
You think about dying and a subset of
people actually take action to try to hurt
themselves or kill themselves.
Now it should be said that suicidal
thoughts and behavior don't only happen in
depression, they actually happen,
um, in all types of psychopathology,
but there are particularly
common in depression.
So you have to have at least one at,
uh,
four of those plus sadness or
Anhedonia and the symptoms.
It can't just be a bad
day that you're having.
These symptoms have to be
present persistently for at
least two weeks to get the
diagnosis. Now, truth be told,
most episodes of major depression actually
lasts a lot longer than two weeks.
In fact, the average length of
an episode, if it's not treated,
it's at least six months. So, um,
people stay this miserable for
a very long period of time. Uh,
but the minimum criterion in
the DSM is at least two weeks.
So why don't want to do is to just show
you a short clip of a woman who has had
a lot of episodes of depression.
Fortunately at the moment
she's not in an episode, um,
but she can speak very articulately about
what it's like to be in the midst of
an episode and some of the
significant symptoms that she had.
Okay.
There are a couple of things she talks
about that I just want to comment on.
One is this,
this differentiation between every day
sad mood and the kind of depressions we
all experience and the
kind of debilitating,
overwhelming depression
that she experiences.
And it is true that there
is this continuum from um,
getting bummed out because you didn't do
well on a test or because you broke up
with him boyfriend or girlfriend or
something like this and being completely
nonfunctional vegetative,
um, the way that this,
this woman becomes whenever
she gets depressed. Um,
and it would be nice if we were really
sure where the cutoff was between those
normal everyday depressions
and what's really a disorder.
But the reality is we don't,
we don't really have real
clear demarcation lines.
There are a lot of people who have more
moderate forms of depression then Tara
here talks about,
but who still would qualify
for a diagnosis and are
still suffering and impaired
by their symptoms.
So I don't want you to get the sense
that that if you don't have the kind of
horrible version,
I'm on the extreme end of the
continuum of depression that Tara has,
then there's nothing wrong with you
because that's not the case. Um,
people who are, are really slowed
down who their functioning is,
is interfered with. They're just
really unhappy with life. Um, uh,
have problems that can be,
can be helped and do need attention.
And it is the case that much more moderate
forms of depression can morph into
more serious forms if they're left and
treat it. So there is this continuum.
The other thing I wanted to comment on
that she talks about it early on in this
piece is,
um,
the fact that she hauls herself up and
goes through her day even when she's
feeling really,
really depressed.
And there is this characteristic
of a lot of depressed people, um,
that I call the walking wounded. Uh, they,
they just haul themselves
through the trying to act normal,
trying not to let anybody know that
there's anything wrong with them.
I'm trying to keep up with
their schoolwork or their
work, um, their employment,
but, but they're miserable and they're
not functioning at the level that they're
capable of and such.
And that's something that's very,
very common and it's in part because,
um,
people don't feel as though they should
have to get treatment or they're ashamed
of getting treatment or
seeking help for depression.
And so they just keep going on
and going on. Sometimes for years,
I'm in a very sorry state, uh,
before sometimes they just,
they end up actually falling apart to
the point where they have to get help.
Okay.
Um,
the other category of mood disorders
that I mentioned are bipolar disorders.
And as I said, bipolar
disorder involves symptoms, uh,
or periods of depression,
but then also distinct periods
of the opposite of depression,
which we call mania.
So the person's cycles back and forth
between debilitating depressions and manic
episodes. So let me describe
manic episodes to you now.
So the first criterion is that instead
of feeling down blue or depressed,
the person has an abnormally
and persistently elevated,
expansive or irritable mood
that isn't just, again,
a good day because you
won a prize or got an a,
but rather it's this unusually positive,
expansive mood for at least
one week persistently.
And then the person has to have three
or more of the following symptoms.
First inflated self esteem or grandiosity.
The individual may feel as though they
are the smartest, the most, um, uh,
created insightful,
powerful person on earth.
And they are perfectly
happy to tell you this. Um,
so there is no problem with self esteem.
Thank you very much.
If you can't keep up with me,
it's your fault. Okay. Um,
there's a decreased need for sleep.
They may only sleep a couple of hours
a night and get up raring to go. Um,
they tend to be more talkative than usual
and there's a real pressure to their
talk. They'll talk really pressured
and they'll talk really, really fast.
And they're one of the
reasons we're talking really,
really fast as they have
this flight of ideas.
The thoughts are just racing through
their mind and they can't talk bathroom,
I have to get them out.
And if you can't follow them that well,
that's because you're not
smart enough to follow them,
but they've just got too many good ideas
and they got to get 'em out, you know,
highly distractible. And then, um,
there is this increase in this
weather what the DSM causes,
goal directed activity out
of the grandiosity will
come these grand schemes for
often for making a lot of money.
Um,
and they'll pursue these with great vigor
no matter how totally irrational they
are.
So it's not at all uncommon for them to
cash out all the family bank accounts to
sell the house,
to sell the car,
to sell the kids so that they can finance
this great scheme for making a zillion
dollars on the Internet
tomorrow. Right. Okay. So,
and they'll pursue this with tremendous,
bigger,
they'll also get involved in all kinds of,
with the DSM discretely calls pleasurable,
but the dangerous activities. Um,
there's a lot of sexual promiscuity,
a lot of drug abuse, a lot of, um,
um, uh, as I think getting,
uh, going and gambling,
believing that you're on a hot streak,
there's nothing can stop you. You know,
you're just, you're just so brilliant.
He got the scheme, you got to plan,
you're going to, you're
going to make it. Okay.
So the individual has three or more
of these kinds of symptoms, uh,
plus this elevated, expansive,
and often quite irritable mood.
It's not just they're happy,
you know, and sort of upbeat.
It's just that they're just impatient
and irritable and trigger fire.
And sometimes they can become
violent because they, they're just,
they're so incredibly
agitated and irritable.
So let me show you a couple of clips.
I have one really short one.
It's not a real high quality clip,
but it's a very,
very nice example of an older woman who
was in the midst of a manic episode and
it shows how, what this kind of
agitation and flight of ideas and,
and racing thoughts, um, can look
like. And then the other one is,
is all introduced whenever we do.
So, um, while she was at the
hairdresser, it was, it's,
it's a nice example of how
she just pressured to speak.
Nobody was telling her that she
had to say all of these things.
They were just standing there with the
camera and she was going on and on and on
about these things.
Um, and as you can see,
she was getting more and more agitated
and more and more irritated, um,
as she was retelling our story.
And then, um, what, uh, uh,
in the last little bit there,
you saw her flip from Romania
into a more depressed state. And,
um, this, this poor
lady unfortunately, uh,
is having a hard time
finding a stable point.
He talked about lithium there and I'll
talk about it in a little bit about the
use of lithium as a drug to try to
stabilize these mood swings. Um,
but at this point in this video,
it's not working for this lady and so
she's, she's flipping back and forth.
Um, but they're having a hard
time finding that middle ground.
So I want to show you another clip.
It's a little bit longer of a man who
has bipolar disorder and he is not
currently in an episode of either
depression or mania. Um, but again,
he can talk about some of the things he
got himself into and how it manifested
in his behavior.
Okay.
Uh, just a couple of things that Bernie
talks about that I want to comment on.
One is that just as in
depression, mania has, uh,
runs along a continuum,
so it can be relatively mild,
um, all the way to extremely
severe and even psychotic.
So when a person with mania loses
touch with reality, instead of having,
um, uh, beliefs that they
are Satan or some whore,
they've done some horrible thing,
they'll believe that they are
some supernatural being. Um,
they may believe that they are the
Messiah or that they are Albert Einstein,
you know,
come back to live or that they have
supernatural powers or something of this
sort so that there,
there are false beliefs,
their delusions and their hallucinations
and things that they see in here that
aren't really, there tend to be
a very grandiose in their themes.
Bernie's MMA mania is not on the far
end of the continuum by any stretch,
but you can see it still
gets him into trouble. Now,
there are people who have,
who cycled between fairly low levels
of mania and fairly low levels of
depression back and forth.
And there's been some argument that,
um, people who are kind of
chronically mildly manic,
especially if they're really smart
or they have a special talent,
can make it work for
them. Um, and there, uh,
is a wonderful book by Kay Jamison,
who's a professor at Johns Hopkins,
um, where she chronicle. She
does sort of historical, um,
die biographies on a number
of a well known, um, uh,
authors and poets and musicians,
Robert Schumann, um, uh, and
a number of politicians, uh,
Winston Churchill and such arguing that
they actually had mild forms of bipolar
disorder and,
uh,
that they were able to sort of channel
the manic episodes through extraordinary
talent or intelligence, um, in
ways that made it work for them.
They're also the number of
arguments that, that, um, very,
very successful CEOs sometimes are people
who are chronically slightly manic.
Um, they can go on to a couple
of hours a night to sleep.
They're obviously really quite grandiose
and self confident and that they can
maintain this kind of
moderate level of mania.
I keep it under control and channel
it in ways that works for them. Uh,
so if you're interested in that book,
uh,
send me an email and I'm happy
to send you the citation for it.
But for the most part,
um,
mania can get people into
tremendous trouble. Um, they,
they can,
as I said,
get involved in sexual promiscuity
that puts them at risk for sexually
transmitted diseases. They can
get involved in drug activity. Um,
they get themselves arrested.
They can certainly send themselves
and their family into bankruptcy. Um,
and these kinds of negative consequences
of the mania often are what motivates
the person to get help because the media
itself can be rather pleasurable to
have.
Um,
also what motivates them to get help
is the plunge into depression. Uh,
the knowledge that they will at some
point come out of the mania and go into a
debilitating depression.
Bipolar disorder is much
less common than depression.
I said that about 22% of women in about
13% of men will have an episode of
serious depression at sometime
in their lives. Um, uh,
bipolar disorder occurs and only about
1% of the population and it's equally
prevalent in women and men.
So it's a really quite different
disorder in many ways. Um,
from a depression alone.
I'm gonna give you some other statistics
about depression per se. And this is,
this only applies to depression.
There are quite large age differences
in the prevalence of of depression.
These are data from a nationwide study
of people between the ages of 15 and 55
and these are the percentage of
people in the, in this study.
And there were several
thousand people in this study.
These are not people who have
sought treatment for depression,
but just a random community sample.
And this is the percentage.
You've had an episode of major depression
in the past month. And as you can see,
um,
the 15 to 24 age range is,
has the highest rates and
then they go down some white.
All of the 35 to 44 is
fairly high as well with age.
Um, you might be surprised to learn that
the rates of major depression in the
elderly are actually quite low
by most national statistics. Um,
and uh,
that's true up to about age 80 or 85.
But, um, and,
and the arguments for why this
is the case are very interesting.
There are some people who argue that
as you get older, you get wiser.
And so that's, that's why we see a
lower rates of depression in older age.
There are other people who
argue that current generation,
younger generations now
your generation and,
and the one above you are more prone to
depression and will be for the rest of
your life compared to your grandparents
because of historical changes in the
kinds of social support and family
networks available. Um, and,
and a number of other
historical cultural changes.
The other sort of side of the argument
is that because depression is known to
um, uh, impact negatively,
your physical health,
depression is associated with higher
rates of cardiovascular disease, stroke,
immune system diseases, a whole host
of diseases that people die from,
that people who have a lifelong history
of depression are actually more likely
to die at an earlier age.
And that's why we see relatively
low rates in older age people.
We don't know yet which of
these explanations is true.
It may be that they're
all true to some extent.
There are gender difference
and in depression, um,
these are data from a compilation of,
of hundreds of studies of children
and adolescence looking at a,
not full blown depression,
but levels of depression on
self report questionnaires.
Probably most of you have filled out
these questionnaires like the Beck
depression inventory that ask you how,
how you've been feeling in the last month.
And there's a kitty version of this and
these are data from that from several
thousand children.
And as you can see here,
prior to the age of about 13 boys and
girls have relatively similar or levels of
depression.
But beginning around the pubertal years,
girls rates and depression go up quite
dramatically and boys rates stayed the
same or go down.
And by the time they're 18 or 20,
you get almost a two to one ratio of
depress girls to depress boys. And,
and this is true for the rest
of the adult age span. Uh,
there are lots of hypotheses
about this, uh, why it's true.
There are biological hypotheses
that have to do with hormones.
There are sociological hypotheses that
have to do with the kinds of stress and
particularly abuse in girls'
lives relative to boys.
We don't know exactly why.
It's probably a lot of these things
coming together that make this huge two to
one ratio.
True.
So let's talk a little bit about the
major theories and treatments for the mood
disorders. There are biological
theories and treatments,
what are known as cognitive behavioral
theories and treatments and an
interpersonal theories and treatments.
And I'll walk you through
examples of each of these.
So first genetics,
it's pretty clear that genetics
are involved in the mood disorders,
especially bipolar disorder.
There is,
there's very strong evidence in bipolar
disorder and there's a number of ways.
Um, have you talked about
how you do genetic studies?
Okay, so you guys know, uh,
about twin studies, for example,
um, and family history studies.
So this is actually a compilation
of a group of studies.
Um, and here you've got some of
them, twins studies compared.
So in monozygotic twins,
if you're identical,
twin has bipolar disorder,
you have over a 60% chance of having
the disorder yourself. In contrast,
if it's your,
if you're just a fraternal twin
of a person with bipolar disorder,
you only have about a 12%
chance of having the disorder.
So that Nath of difference,
there is very strong evidence that
there's a genetic component to the
transmission of the disorder.
Similarly,
the more distance you get in terms of,
um,
your biological relation to a
person with bipolar disorder,
the lower your rate or your
risk of the disorder is. So,
um, the second degree relatives, uh,
the person with bipolar disorder only
have about a 2% chance of getting the
disorder and that's barely above
what's in the general population,
which is about a 1% chance of
getting the disorders. So, um,
it's very clear that bipolar disorder
has a genetic component to it with
depression alone, a major depression. Uh,
there are probably versions of the
disorder that have a stronger genetic
component to it than others.
And in particular, um,
folks who have what's called early onset
depression where their first episodes
come on in childhood or
very early adolescence, um,
seem to have a form of depression that
has a stronger genetic component to it.
Whereas people who have depression that
is clearly triggered by a major life
event,
like a trauma or a loss,
those types of depression or less clearly
linked strongly to to genetic factors.
Okay.
There are also a number
of neurotransmitters that
have been implicated in the
mood disorders and the
class of neurotransmitters
that's been researched most
often are what's called the Mano lambings.
I'm sure you've heard about the link
between Serotonin and depression,
but there are two other monoamines a
norepinephrine and dopamine that have also
been linked to, um, to that
both of the mood disorders,
both bipolar disorder
and um, uh, depression.
And it used to be thought that it was
just that in people with depression,
they didn't have enough of these,
a neurotransmitter's enough
serotonin in particular, um,
in the system in the
brain, um, in order to, uh,
function normally.
Uh,
but now the theories on what the
role of neurotransmitters are,
have a lot more to do with the receptors
for these neurotransmitters and their
functioning.
And the notion is that the receptors for
neurotransmitters like Serotonin don't
function efficience.
So even if there's enough of the,
the chemical in the synapsis in the brain,
the neurons can't make use of them
because the receptors aren't functioning
appropriately.
And so what the drugs that help relieve
depression too is to improve the
functioning of these neurotransmitters.
There's a very interesting line of work
that's going on right now looking at the
intersection of genetic predisposition,
neurotransmitter functioning and stress.
Um,
and we have one of the world's experts
on this kind of work now here at Yale,
Julia Kim calling, uh, who just
joined us in the last year.
But there are several recent studies.
There's another person in psychiatry,
Jon Kaufman, um, who's
done some of this work.
But there are several recent studies
that find that certain variations or
polymorphisms on the serotonin
transporter gene predict who will become
depressed,
depressed in the face of stress.
So the classic study was done by Avshalom
Caspi and colleagues and they found
that people who have a one or two of
what's called the short ilial on the
serotonin transporter gene.
So this is a particular,
a variation on the
serotonin transporter gene.
If they had one or two
of these short illegals,
um,
and they were confronted with stress,
they were more likely to develop,
I'm sorry,
these are these to develop depression.
But um,
it's important to sort of dissect this.
So people who had it didn't really
matter which of these genes you had.
Um, if you were never
confronted with major kinds of,
of stress like maltreatment, um, if
you weren't confronted with stress,
the you were no more likely
to have depression, uh,
regardless of what kind of of
a Serotonin Jeanne you had.
But if you had either a one shorter
lel or too short illegals and you were
confronted with maltreatment as a child,
you had a much greater probability of
becoming at some time in your life.
And this has been replicated
with other samples,
with other forms of major trauma.
And basically the story is it takes the
intersection of a genetic predisposition
and major stress to create full
blown depression in some people.
Now that may not be true for all
genetic predispositions are all forms of
depression.
Uh,
but this serotonin finding is actually
been replicated now in at least four
different studies.
So it seems to be a,
a pretty reliable effect.
So it again,
genes do not determine, um, the disorder,
but the intersection of genes and stress,
um,
seem to be a major risk
factor for the disorder.
There are a number of brain areas that
seem to be involved in the mood disorders
where there's just
dysregulation or dysfunction.
The prefrontal Cortex, as you probably
have studied, is an area of the brain.
It's very involved in,
in higher order,
complex thinking and problem solving
and in goal directed behavior in people
with depression.
There's lowered activity in the
prefrontal cortex suggesting that,
uh, at which may play a
role in the, in the, uh,
difficulties in concentration and a
goal directed behavior in planning and
problem solving.
And in regulating emotion,
the Amygdala is an area of the brain
that is involved in the processing of
emotional information and
people with mood disorders,
overactive Amygdala Amygdala
responses to emotional information.
Um, this is true in both bipolar
and in, um, in, uh, depression.
The hippocampus is an area of the brain
that's very involved in memory and in
concentration.
And in people with chronic depression,
you often see shrinkage
in the hippocampus, uh,
and this may be related to their
problems in concentration and attention.
And then finally,
the anterior singular is an area of
the brain that's involved in a lot of
different activities, but, uh,
pertinent to the mood disorders,
particularly in responses to distress
or to stress and in a sort of the choice
of behaviors. And it may be that, um,
a dysregulation of anterior singlet
maybe involved in the person's difficulty
and responding appropriately to stress
in choosing good coping behaviors in
changing their behaviors whenever
their behaviors aren't working well.
So from the biological theories come a
number of different drugs to treat the
mood disorders.
Um,
two of the older classes are called
the monoamine oxidase inhibitors.
And the try [inaudible] Canada precedence
and it twice actually because is still
use these days to some extent
they're relatively effective.
The about 60% of people respond
well to the tricyclics, um,
but they have a lot of side effects and
they can be fatal and overdose. And so,
um, there was uh, uh,
has been always a search for
other alternatives to them.
The drugs that have really taken over
the market are this selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitors or Sris.
This is Paxil PROZAC and the like.
They were introduced in 1987.
PROZAC was in the u s market and truly
took over the market and the treatment of
depression and anxiety in a
number of other disorders.
Now they're not that much more
effective than this sort of old style
antidepressants,
but they have fewer side effects and
they tend to be easier for people to
tolerate.
Um,
more recently there are a selective
serotonin norepinephrine reuptake
inhibitors. These drugs, by the way,
what these drugs supposedly do is to
prevent the re uptake of Serotonin or
Serotonin and norepinephrine
norepinephrine back
into the sending neuron.
So it creates more of the neurotransmitter
there in the synapse and these are
reasonably effective drugs,
although again,
there's a substantial number of people
who don't respond to them especially
immediately and they'll often have to
cycle through a number of drugs before
they find one that works.
Lithium as the drug of choice for the
treatment of bipolar disorder, um,
it seems to stabilize the mood swings,
um,
by stabilizing a number of different
neurotransmitter systems. Um, and,
but, uh, lithium is problematic because
there are tremendous side effects.
It's also dangerous for women to take
while they're pregnant in terms of fetal
development. Um, so it's, it's
a very tough drug to stay on.
There are lots of gastrointestinal
side effects and such,
and people are often on lithium and the
antidepressants because lithium often
only affects the manic episodes, but it
doesn't really relieve the depression.
Um, and then finally,
antipsychotic medications, that is,
those that help people who've lost
touch with reality are sometimes used to
treat the mood disorders whenever the
person has lost touch with reality.
I'm going to go through and talk about
some of the psychosocial treatments,
uh,
because I want to get to them as well.
The cognitive behavioral
therapies are based on, uh, uh,
Aaron backs negative cognitive
theory of depression. Um,
Aaron Beck is a psychiatrist at the
University of Pennsylvania who really
founded this whole line of work.
Um, and according to Beck, this,
now this applies to depression alone.
It doesn't really apply
to bipolar disorder.
People who are depressed have
a negative view of the self,
of the future and of the world. And he
calls us the negative cognitive triad.
And this negative cognitive triad is
fed by specific cognitive deficits or
biases. So depressed people show
a lot of distortions and thinking,
I'm all or nothing,
thinking is thinking that I'm being
are either all good or all bad.
They can't sort of see
the gray areas in between.
There's emotional reasoning.
Um,
and an example of that is just if I
feel like a loser, I must be a loser.
Or if I feel stupid, I must be stupid. Um,
and then personalization that is the self
blame that you often see in depressed
people and these kinds of distortions
and thinking these distorted ways of
interpreting situations,
um,
feed it kind of general negative view
of the self and a hopelessness about the
future.
Um,
people who are depressed also make
attributions for negative events that are
internal, that is, they blame
themselves, uh, that are stable.
They see things bad things as lasting
forever and that are global. They see bad,
uh, bad events as affecting
many areas of their life,
which again feeds their depression and
their general assumption that that life
is terrible and evidence that these,
um,
for these cognitive theories that these
cognitive negative cognitive styles
predict depression. One of the best
studies, uh, predicting this was studied.
It was jointly done at Temple University
and University of Wisconsin where they
identified first year of college
students with a negative cognitive or
attributional style.
But these were people who had never
experienced an episode of depression yet
they then track them for the
next two years. And the is here.
The red bars are the,
uh,
percent of those with a negative cognitive
style who developed an episode of
major depression in that two and a
half years versus the percent of those
without a negative cognitive style.
And as you can see,
there's quite a substantial difference
between the two. So prospectively,
these cognitive characteristics seem
to predict your risk for depression.
In turn, there's a cognitive behavioral
therapy that's based on beccs, um,
theory and the major steps in this
involved in identifying the themes in a
person's negative thoughts
and triggers for them.
And then helping the person
challenged those thoughts by, uh,
asking them what the evidence
is for their interpretations,
whether there are other ways
of looking at this situation,
how they can cope with the situation
if the bad thing really did happen.
So the therapist helps the
client recognized negative
beliefs or assumptions, um,
and in challenged these a challenge,
the truth value of these and,
and change aspects of the environment
that are related to depressive symptoms.
So they challenge your rational thinking,
but they also recognize that there are
really bad things that sometimes they're
going on in the life of a person who's
depressed and they helped them engage in
more active problem solving to
change those environments. Um,
they also teach the person
ways to manage their mood, um,
so that they don't tumble
down into depression.
And these cognitive behavioral therapies
have been shown to be extremely
effective, um, and as effective
in some ways as the, uh,
uh,
the drug treatments.
So this is a reason study in which they
had 240 patients with major depressive
disorder.
Um,
they gave them four months of acute
treatment with either cognitive behavioral
therapy or Paxil,
which is an Ssri.
And in eight weeks here,
they also had a placebo control
group where they just got a pill,
but it was a sugar pill at eight weeks.
The Paxil group,
which is in red, and the CVP group,
which is in yellow. We're relatively,
even all of the Paxil group had a little
bit of an edge over the CBT group,
but by 16 weeks,
the Paxil and the CBT group were
absolutely even in terms of the percent of
people who were no
longer, um, uh, depressed.
So both of them resulted in about 60%
of people not being depressed. And then,
um, one of the things that's been found
over and over again with cognitive
behavioral therapy is that it not only
helps people get out of a current episode
of depression,
it helps to prevent future episodes of
depression because it teaches the person
new coping skills for dealing
with new stressors that arise.
So in this same study,
they followed the patients for
an additional 12 months and, um,
other Paxil group,
half were left on full dose medications
to see if you could prevent depression
by just keeping people on the meds.
And half of the pack full group were
withdrawn to a placebo. And, um,
let's look at the Placebo
Group first here. Um,
this is the sad news about depression.
If you just take drugs to get out of a
current episode and you go off of the
drugs without having any
kind of psychotherapy,
your rate of relapse tends to be
very high. So in this group of 240,
almost 80% relapsed in
the first year after, um,
going off of the active medication.
Again,
these were people who did not get
any cognitive behavioral therapy. Um,
of those people who stayed on Paxil alone,
about 50% relapsed. But of those people
who got cognitive behavioral therapy,
only about 35% relapsed.
So,
and this kind of a I'm finding has
been replicated over and over again,
namely that CVT can reduce the rate of
relapse in depression quite dramatically.
I give you a flavor for what
CBT looks like. Um, and uh,
cause I've got a short clip of a
therapist who's actually interestingly the
daughter of Aaron Beck and
his air in terms of the, uh,
um, the practice and, and development
of cognitive behavioral therapy.
And she's, um, demonstrating CBT.
This is actually a role play,
but it's a pretty realistic role play
of how she goes after and helps to
challenge. I'm a gentleman's, uh,
negative cognitions about himself.
This is the guy in the roleplay who's,
uh,
recently lost his job and he's
really depressed over his job loss.
Okay. I'm going to stop there
cause we're running out of time,
but I just want to comment on a
couple of things that she's doing.
So you see that she's,
um,
she's having him generate
his own challenges to his
negative thoughts and write
them down. And the whole,
one of the major premises in,
in CBT is it's not just what goes on in
the therapy session that is effective.
In fact,
that's a minor part of it.
But what the person practices in the
time between therapy sessions and so what
she's doing is helping him come up
with a series of phrases he can say to
himself when he feels discouraged
and plunging down. Um,
she's also helping him do what's
called anticipatory coping,
anticipating those situations that are
going to trigger negative feelings and
negative thoughts and coming up with
ways of combating them in the moment that
he can enact at the time. Cognitive
behavioral therapy is very structured.
It's very focused and it's designed
to be relatively short term.
The one other major kind of psychotherapy
for depression is interpersonal
therapy.
It's based on the theory that negative
views of yourself and expectations about
the self and relationships are based on
upbringings that really fostered these
kind of negative self views.
And so what you need to do is to help
clients understand their negative self
views and how they're rooted
in their past relationships.
Interpersonal therapy is less structured
then cognitive behavioral therapy and
it's more focused on the past.
CBT is very focused on the present and
dealing with the current situation that
you're facing and combating that and
developing coping styles for that.
Um, there are a few studies comparing
interpersonal therapy with CBT.
Um, but much less research has been
done on IPT and CBT, but it is, uh,
a positive alternative for some people,
particularly those who find that their
depression is very tied up in recurrent
themes in the relationships that that
seemed to happen over and over and over
again.
But to end the,
the good news about depression is that
there are these alternative therapies,
there are a number of drug therapies,
and there are at least two psychotherapies
that good controlled research had
been shown,
can be very helpful.
So people have a choice and there is
absolutely no need for people to stay in
depression, but rather, uh, to
seek out the kind of therapy that,
that applies to an appeals to them
the most. Good. Thanks very much.